okay well my name is Angela Marcy I I
live in san paulo brazil i'm an owner of
a small company called sky we are a
consultancy and as that what i do is
work with communications with integrated
marketing and what customer experience I
came here because I'm I've been a fan
since I don't know 2004 or something
where I read that businessweek cover and
I started reading about ideal and the
process of design thinking it was great
coming here and just seeing everything
come to life things that I read things
that I saw on TED Talks and really be
able to experience this moment one of my
favorite moments was David Kelly talking
about his experience in our visit to
ideal that was great one of the most
important things I learned was how to
redefine the issue or the problem Bernie
wroth and his class was great with that
when I realized that sometimes the
question you begin with is really an
answer that's framing and closing the
possibilities for your fraud problem
then that just hit me you know there's a
good balance between the methodology and
the practice and you get to learn a lot
by doing and by making mistakes and by
making good stuff too so I loved it
you